in 1984 the computer scientist aaron
sloman published a paper arguing that we
need more systematic thinking about
minds and he said it was time to admit
into that conversation what we had
learned about
animal cognition
as well as what research on ai and
computer science had told us he said
clearly there's not just one sort of
mind besides obvious differences between
adults there are differences between
adults children of various ages and
infants there are cross-cultural
differences there are also differences
between humans chimpanzees dogs mice and
other animals and there are differences
between all those and machines
and his paper was entitled the structure
of the space of possible minds and he
was arguing that minds exist not just
along a a line that measures something
like intelligence but in a
rich multi-dimensional
space
and this blending of computer science
and behaviorism must have seemed a bit
eccentric in the 1980s but today it
looks astonishingly prescient
although this cartography of the space
of possible minds has barely begun
this is a really good time to start
thinking about what it might look like
not only has ai at last started to prove
its value but there's a perception that
making further improvements to ai and
getting anything like artificial like
general ai
human like ai will require a close
consideration of how today's putative
machine minds actually function and how
they differ from our own and our
understanding of animal cognition too
has gotten much richer in the past
decades or two in part because of the
possibilities that neuroscience and
information technologies have opened up
and so today we can find child
psychologists talking to roboticists and
computer engineers and
neurologists talking to marine
biologists
we have some of the conceptual tools and
some of the experimental tools to start
mapping out this landscape of mines
um i i guess i need to start by asking
that difficult question what is a mind
and
we have to admit there is no scientific
definition that's going to help us here
most of the vast literature that exists
on the philosophy of mind just takes it
for granted that we're talking about us
okay um the philosopher daniel dennett
um
he uh started thinking in this way in
his 1996 book kinds of mind and he said
that whatever else a mind is
it is supposed to be something like our
minds otherwise we wouldn't call it a
mind
so mind is one of those concepts like
like intelligence like thought like life
that sounds kind of technical but it's
actually a bit fuzzy and and colloquial
now i propose to talk about it in a
similar way to the way john cell the
philosopher of mine talked about
consciousness um so i'm saying that for
an entity to have a mind there must be
something it is like to be that entity
so i don't believe that you know this
glass has a mind i don't think it has an
experience i don't think that uh asking
what it's like to be this glass
means anything at all
on the other hand i reckon that most
people are probably ready to accept that
say an orangutan has a mind you might
consider there's something it is like to
be a mouse
perhaps even a fly
maybe a fungus
maybe that's pushing it a bit too far
although we'll return to that question
uh in a bit
um and i think it makes sense to speak
there not in terms of things that
absolutely do or don't have a mind but
of mindedness to to to acknowledge that
it's not an all or nothing attribute
it's a matter of degree and one of the
benefits of thinking about a space of
possible minds is that we can think
about those matters of degree in
many attributes many different
dimensions coordinates of that space and
let me illustrate um what this might
mean by just uh telling you about a
couple of efforts to say what mindspace
might look like previously so a simple
and ingenious way to start drawing this
map was devised by some american
psychologists daniel wegner kurt gray
and heather gray in 2007
and they asked p they simply asked
people what people thought about what
mines were like minds not just of humans
but also things like robots and
companies and supernatural agents ghosts
and god
what attributes do we think
they have
surprisingly the responses they got
could be boiled down to a space of
possible minds that had just two key
attributes label that they labeled
experience and agency and here
experience means how much inner life the
entity has so a capacity for things like
fear and pain and hunger and pleasure
and joy
the agency meanwhile refers to the
ability to do things to accomplish goals
to possess memory to plan and
communicate so really this was a space
of possible perceived minds what we
humans imagine that space might look
like and it could be because it just had
these two dimensions you could plot it
as a sort of uh two-dimensional graph on
which every kind of mind could be a
single data point on that graph and it
was striking that one of the things that
came out of this was that people think
that there isn't just a place where
human minds go that we actually have a
trajectory we follow through life so
babies were in one place they were
actually rated by people as having a
higher experience than an adult mind but
much lower agency so you know for a baby
everything is intensely felt but they
don't get much done
and so we follow that trajectory you
know as children and then we get to the
human mind and interestingly even when
we die people perceive that we don't
leave the map there's a space on that
map where people think dead people are
um
and another attempt to plot out a space
of mines has been made by the
neuroscientist christophe [ __ ]
his mind space is also two-dimensional
he gives it coordinates of intelligence
and consciousness
so we have both and in terms of uh
thinking about animals it's actually
quite a simple plot it's just a kind of
diagonal line where we're sort of up
here at the top with the most amount of
intelligence and consciousness and then
other animals you know dogs and cats and
then you get all the way down to
jellyfish sort of down here or on there
but christoph also thought we can put
other things in this space we can put
for example um ai and and computers
which uh in his view have intelligence
but don't have really any significant
consciousness at all and he feels that
actually that's not likely to change
anytime soon perhaps never
now in both of these uh mind spaces we
are sort of up there in the top right
corner so we have the maximum amount of
these attributes and we're really
assessing all other minds relative to us
and how they you know comparing them to
how they how they compare with us well
that's just the way we are right we're
eager egotists but perhaps that's
inevitable as dennis says it's hard to
even think about what minds might mean
unless it's in reference to our own so
let's start thinking about our own minds
the philosopher ned block um also
suggested there are two attributes of
human minds but his were
intelligence which he by which he meant
an information processing capacity that
turns a stimulus into a behavior and
intentionality
and intentionality uh supplies the
purpose and the motive for that behavior
by somehow relating it to the world
around us
dennett argues that to have intentions
means that the mind must be a generator
of expectations and predictions you know
what else is an intention but a hope a
wish for certain outcomes in the future
certain outcomes that we consider to be
at least possible dennis says that the
mind minds the present for clues which
it refines with the help of materials
that are saved from the past
turning them into anticipation of the
future and then it acts rationally on
the basis of those hard-won
anticipations
and this view of the human mind as a
predictor i think suggests how it
differs from a machine-like stimulus
response system because not only are our
decisions and predictions often as you
might have noticed rather poor for
actually obtaining our goals but most of
the time we're not even sure what the
goal really is or rather we might have
many conflicting goals and not the
slightest idea of how to calculate a
route between them
and i'd suggest that our minds as well
as those of other animals are not
stimulus response circuits machine-like
systems for creating actions but they're
actually the alternative to that sort of
automaton-like behavior so the simplest
organisms like bacteria
are they often show behavior that is is
hardwired they have a very limited
repertoire of actions uh that are
generated reliably and predictably by
certain stimuli from the environment now
even that is simplifying it for bacteria
they're more complex than that but you
can see that that's the kind of behavior
they tend to have
our minds exist i think to free us from
that to free us if you like from our
genetic hard wiring by allowing us
actions that aren't pre-programmed
the amazing thing about humans is not
that our genes affect the way we think
and the choices we make they undoubtedly
do
but how much of our behavior seems to
escape their dominating influence
complex minds have a vast repertoire
of behaviors that can be fine-tuned and
adjusted and actually improvised to the
circumstances and actually this makes
evolutionary sense because if evolution
wants to give a creature to put it very
anthropomorphically wants to give a
creature lots of behavioral options for
surviving in a complex environment then
it can either invest a lot in hard
wiring a response to every foreseeable
circumstance or and this seems a much
more efficient way to do things or it
can build that creature a mind
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you